I have a rule of three in my mind if
there's something I see you do that rubs
me the wrong way I make a little note of
it and I won't talk about it unless it
happens three times oo tell me one let
me think you're not going to upset me
okay look at me
though but you're not going to upset me
okay but
hey people are watching you're not going
to upset me do not embarrass me
say it I'm fine say whatever the three
thing was my mom watches this
show I can't bre this morning um Let me
let me think you will do a beard trim oh
yeah and then you'll leave your hairs
around the sink it is adorable that you
think it's my beard
hair it is so cute you're like oh
there's a beard hair on my toothbrush
how did it get over here and I'm just
like just combing your pubes with my
toothbrush absolutely